[Music]
on today's show we talk about in-laws
should we be living with them after
eight years should i keep working for my
father-in-law no
and we also talked to an awesome guy who
just got a new job and his anxieties
through the roof stay tuned
[Music]
heyo
it's john with the dr john deloney's
show we're taking your calls on life and
love and happiness
and parenting
misery
sadness
all all the things
man if you want to be on the show give
me a call at 1-844
that's 1-844-693-3291
or go to johndaloni.com
ask and by the way while you're there
go to johndaloni.com
down and sign up for the newsletter
it is dope on a rope
nope not dope it is
i don't know
neat in a seat what are we gonna say
here
it is
it's turning
why'd you have to bring dr seuss up
james
she's a wheeze man did he get canceled i
haven't for sure okay i haven't heard
yeah real cool james just
we had a nice show going and it just got
dark all of a sudden so let's just back
that thing up and go to john
dillinger.com and sign up for our
newsletter
and
new thing
um
so i make jokes all the time about this
show only having like you know five
people listening to it whatever
that's not true
it's blown up out from underneath us
and
i want to get it out there even more
so
here's what i'm asking you to do if
you're listening to this podcast today
go back to your favorite episode it may
not be this one this one i mean or
something so great it may be this one
go back to you your favorite episode and
send it to one person
just send it to one person
say hey this made me think of you
if it made you think of them awesome if
you think they would like it great
if it's
if it's about bad in-laws send it to
your mother-in-law that will help with
thanksgiving
um but send it to one person let's get
the word out um i'm so grateful for the
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people that are listening it's just
really humbling and it's cool
and let's get it out there more let's
get it out there more
um send it to somebody that you care
about i had this um somebody slid into
my dms
i just i can't say that it's just so
gross it gives me the heebs this dude
reached out on the internet how about
that
and he said this is just what he wrote
dude
the silent eye contact physical touch
and gratitude lists
not only improved things between my wife
and i but one thing led to another and
my entire world has been revolutionized
i've begun sponsoring an aaa i started
brazilian jiu jitsu i enjoy playing
music again and on and on can't thank
you enough
dude
i'm not gonna give call your name out
because um i didn't i didn't ask your
permission here but i get notes like
this all the time that say people are
listening they're putting these little
things into practice
these little bitty things
like asking your wife what's your
picture of today like writing a note to
your son saying hey i love you man
like
getting a morning routine whether it's
big or it's little
i just quit eating sugar whether it's
deciding to call your mom once a week
whatever it is
people are implementing these little
bitty behaviors these little bitty
changes and they're doing them over and
over and they're seeing massive changes
in their life thank you so so much for
these notes that you send thanks for
joining us on the show for listening and
listening and listening i'm so grateful
all right let's go to joe in orlando
let's get orlando hey man i'm orlando
orlando joe in orlando wouldn't you know
what's up
hi john thank you for having me on the
show i'm a big fan you got it man i'm a
big fan of you what's up
uh so uh keeping it short i'm 26
married and i'm having troubles with my
in-laws
what kind of troubles
me and my wife have been living with my
in-laws ever since we got married
due to
uh going to school going to work and all
that
back that thing up um
how long y'all been married
2015 so gonna be
about eight years in november
and you've been living with them all
this time
yeah i don't even know what you're about
to say and i will tell you yes you
probably have problems with your in-laws
my guess is and i went to a lot of grad
school and i'm a genius
my guess is if you live with your
in-laws for the better part of a decade
in a new young marriage you're probably
gonna have problems with your in-laws
why are you living at home with your
in-laws
so initially it was an agreement
between me and my wife while we finished
school
did you make drugs
we got married in our second year
college
i had just turned 21.
oh my gosh
i know that sounded like a good idea
that was probably even a worse idea so
you at 21
you were out you were a junior in
college i guess
uh second year second year sophomore and
what year was she
no sophomore as well we're the same age
oh man
and
is there like an apartment or a back
house or are you just like down the hall
down the hall
oh
gosh
so let me just back up here
yeah
sophomores in college
daughter comes home and says i found my
husband i'm gonna marry him soon
and we're gonna move back into my
my old high school bedroom is that right
no
so
uh when we got married we had moved from
puerto rico here to orlando uh-huh
um
so we had found initially an apartment
just for us okay but then her family
came along and we decided to group into
a larger apartment
her mother-in-law and father-in-law had
some issues
so they split up
we changed to a new apartment where we
are now which is a lot smaller so
the space is very uncomfortable but
tensions between my mother-in-law and
myself
keep growing throughout the years and i
can't find a way of convincing my wife
that it's time to move out
especially now since my mother-in-law
deute lost her job so technically we're
paying
for
the majority of expenses
brother
and i i'm not trying to paint that she's
a terrible person no dude you don't have
to you don't have to
i love my mom
i love my mother-in-law
i could not live in an apartment with
her for a decade either of them
yeah
and so
you and you can't
either
your mother-in-law cannot respect
you
because you still live in her apartment
as the as the
as the man who married her
daughter and this isn't like a
like a gendered thing like a paternal
thing
this is
you promise to take care of my daughter
and still living in my apartment
oh she doesn't want us to leave that's
the issue
i know
it's the it's a catch-22 dance you're in
she can't respect you and she doesn't
want you to leave
and
your wife is stuck
dude i don't know i don't say is you got
to move and i know that you know that
but
there's no amount this is eight years as
a decade there's no amount of gentle
conversations you all may have to help
pay for rent for a season or your
mother-in-law's gotta get a job
there is no easy way out but you've
gotta move and you've gotta move asap
i know that i just don't know how to let
my wife know because every time we bring
the conversation up
she just tells me she can't because she
has agreed to help her mom out then you
have to hear that for what it is
your wife is choosing her mother over
you your wife is saying i don't want to
be married to you anymore i want to be
my mother's i still want to i want to
live at home with my mom
and so you have to
do what
i guess that's what i'm afraid of don't
be afraid of it it's happened
it's not a mite it's an is
but sometimes
my guess is you beat around the bush a
little bit and you say well i just
really think it's about time
i think you've got to be bold and you've
got to say
it's time to move out 60 days we're out
of here
you're going on a decade man how old are
you
i'm 26. what do you do for a
living i just graduated at the end of
the summer and i started a
a job at a software engineering company
okay
how much money do you make
right now it's my first year as intern
so 50 000 a year first year as an intern
like an intern position and then after
the first year if i
if i
qualify
like they hire you as an intern for your
first year and then afterwards if you
make the cut you go up to 70.
man that's a
i don't know a lot of 50 000 intern jobs
that's pretty great pretty great pay man
so does your wife work too
uh she works at a walmart okay well
she's still finishing school
are y'all going to grad school or
something what's taking so long
because
uh she's helping pay and we weren't we
didn't qualify for financial aid or
anything we've been paying out of pocket
for college so you're not you're not you
didn't go into a bunch of debt
well i i had that stupid debt before the
marriage my wife says not okay good for
you guys for figuring it out man
yeah um here's what has to happen asap
um let me ask you this you mentioned you
moved from puerto rico
um is there cultural challenges here too
not for me but for her and her family
yes okay is she from puerto rico
no they're from another place they're
from colombia okay uh they struggle a
lot more well i was a struggle there's
just some there's some
uh i want to honor the
cultural differences where you don't
just
the
the a lot of my
a lot of western culture says
suck it up mom you're on your own and
there's other cultures that say no
you're part of our family you're going
to move in
so at some point you've got a
asap you're about to lose your marriage
what's about to happen
you're sick of it you're getting sick of
your wife and you're about to implode is
that fair
i already imploded on my mother-in-law
so yeah i'm pretty close on
like
my temper is getting out of hand
ah hold on hold on you're choosing that
brother
you don't make that choice you got it
okay
don't say it's getting out of hand as
though it's some other thing that's you
making choices
okay if you need to go get a hotel room
because your mother-in-law is yelling at
you or hol or whatever do that be a
person of character
but don't blow up and say it's because
of it it's not you choose that okay take
ownership of your feelings and your
emotions and your thoughts and then take
ownership of your actions
don't let this situation take your
character from you
um
you all have to
let me ask you one more question though
before i start telling you i think you
should do you have your eye on somebody
else
no
no
no
the only people i interact with is my
wife and my best friend who's a guy
other than that
no other social circle okay you've got
to get one by the way
um
this thing is
it's suffocating you and you know that
um yeah the time for the conversation is
is now
where you need to take your wife out to
dinner and say we've talked about this
we've thought about this we have to move
out of this apartment
um it could be that you rent a small
house and your mother-in-law lives in
your house under your rules
under
um
y'all's your family values of this young
family y'all have not left y'all are
still children y'all are
weird romantic brother and sister living
in this house you have to get your own
place
with your own values begin creating your
own
here's for me and my house
and your mother-in-law is welcome to
live there
but you can't live in her apartment that
you pay for anymore
okay
and you've got to have a hard
conversation with your wife and if she
says i'm not leaving my mom then you
need to be bold and say
are you choosing to not be married to me
anymore
and you're choosing to live with your
mother instead
you've got to be very clear
very very clear about this
and hopefully she'll say well no i want
both you say awesome i accept both i
understand when i married you
i also married into your
your heart and into your culture and i
married into the idea that we don't put
um our parents in homes they live with
us excellent but they live with us
not us with them
and that sounds like it's just semantics
it's a big difference
and then you and your wife need to have
conversations and discussions who are we
gonna be what is our future vision for
this thing what kind of house are we
going to have we have a joyful house a
dancing house a serious house where are
we going to live what kind of town do we
want to be where are we going to be
those are conversations that y'all too
have together
and mother-in-law can come live with you
and by the way mother-in-law has to get
a job
soon
that means you and your wife have to
have a budget here's what it's going to
cost to live here's what's going to cost
to buy food and home all those things
you have to be very serious about
creating home conversations you should
had eight years ago you didn't cool
period at the end of that sentence
period at the end of that sentence
now it's next now what's next
but yeah joe you gotta get out of that
house holy smoke [ __ ] get out of that
house
and i hope your wife wants to be married
to you
bring your mother-in-law along that's in
your house we'll be right back on the dr
don dolone show
[Music]
hey what's up this is john let's talk
about a good night's sleep
it's important for your physical health
your mental health your sanity you name
it if you're not sleeping good the first
question i want you to ask yourself is
do i need a new mattress and here's how
you tell if you're tossing and turning
all night because you can't get
comfortable if you woke up at night and
you're all hot right or if in the
morning your back hurts if you have any
of these issues you may need to check
out a new mattress
if you're ready for a new mattress i
want you to check out dream cloud it's
the mattress i own and you'll love it
and they're currently running their
biggest offer ever 400 bucks in
accessories plus an additional 250
discount only for delony listeners
that's a total of about 650 in
accessories and savings visit
dreamcloudsleep.com
or
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get a new mattress today and
enjoy 650 bucks in savings that's
dreamcloudsleep.com promo code
d-e-l-o-n-y
good night
all right we're back let's go to mandy
in raleigh north carolina what's up
mandy
hi john how are you doing today i am
dancing like i've never danced before
i'm dancing on the ceiling
what's up i feel ya i'm the same yeah i
uh
i have just received a really awesome
job offer very cool um higher pay actual
benefits compared to what i have now
um and i'm excited about it it's
tentative they're probably gonna give me
a firm offer not sure yet
dude you are
you are
oh man i just asked the girl out and she
said yes we're gonna get married i just
haven't she hasn't fully said yes yet
but she said she would respond to my
texts tomorrow i haven't really even
asked yet but i'm thinking about it's
gonna be so good
well in this context with the type of
job it is it's the tentative means i'll
get it if i pass background checks so
and i don't have any skeletons in my
closet that i know of have you ever been
to jail
i sure have not so thank goodness what a
boring life just kidding good for you
amanda good for you okay so you're
getting this job offer
we're celebrating here everybody let's
all cheer back there in the booth cheer
can't hear them but all right so we're
all excited for you but this sounds like
there's a
wow
there's a butt
currently i work for a family firm
i am one of two professionals in this
firm uh-oh and i nurture a ton of client
relationships i manage a ton of highly
billable projects and i handle crisis
situations for my boss flash family
member pretty frequently so very
valuable in this firm you know has two
professionals in it me and my family
member
and
this is a significant pay raise this is
super great benefit i cannot say no to
this offer but i am going to let down my
family like there's no tomorrow
who's your family member
my in-laws i worked my in-laws oh no
yep what's that they just talked about
an in-law situation before this yes
y'all don't live in the same apartment
do you
oh no no no no no no okay good
night that would have made this call so
much more awesome um
what's the what's the business what's
the firm
um i am a professional accountant and
i'm a cpa
kappa all right so you are a cpa
and a family tax firm an accounting firm
do they make more money and they just
not pay you or is this just as much as
they make
we don't really talk about it i'm an
employee that's it i'm an employee on a
salary that's it i love it dude so great
so you're not a partner at this
accounting firm or anything no
absolutely not i'm so happy
who's the other accountant please say
your father-in-law
yes oh sweet
dude so two cool things are gonna happen
number one you're gonna make a jillion
more dollars and get benefits and
you don't have christmas plans this year
that's so great
let's have more fun do you have uh kids
yes yes how many
one one
is it
please tell me it's the only grandkid
please please please please please
yes oh yes
you're gonna ruin everything mandy
i know
everything
i'm so happy
listen i don't get these kind of calls
very often they're all sad and
depressing you're gonna blow up your
whole family and i'm so excited okay so
obviously i'm i'm laughing because you
okay you know you have to do this
yes do your does your family have any
idea
no none not not not this side of the
family no my my mom knows about it but
that's it so and my husband obviously
okay that's what i was gonna ask
has he been keeping from his parents
yes yes
yikes
so that's where i think this is gonna
get dicey because they've treated you
like an employee
you are an employee on a salary
you get to make grown-up employee
choices for your employee self you're
not a partner you're not you do a lot
for that business and they pay you for
what you do right
and so that's all good
i'm minimizing this this is gonna be a
big thing
where i think this is gonna be a
challenge is
if i'm them i would ask
why didn't you tell us you felt
underpaid
why didn't you at least come talk to us
about this what about this
oh you have okay so tell me about those
conversations
um we don't do performance based um it's
mostly a salary um i've my opinion is i
have really high billable hours the
opinion of
the the partner my father-in-law is i
don't
cool that's great
so
here's
this is this is
one
i'm so happy will you promise before i
tell you anything else you promise
you'll call me back and let me know how
this goes please please please
i will i gotta know how this goes even
if next time you're crying and you're
like they like they hate us and whatever
i just got to know how this thing ends
um
one time i was just flipping channels i
love stand-up comedy i'm kind of
obsessed with it and i don't remember
the name of this comedian but i just
stopped by and this comedian was talking
about driving down the street and it was
like on a telephone pole and he saw one
of those signs it said call this number
and ask me how i lost weight
and
he called it and said hey i'm just
calling to ask you how you lost weight
and then
instead of it being some advertisement
that god the joke was the guy just said
diet and exercise thanks
and hung up so that made me laugh and i
thought that was a hilarious joke
and so i'm telling you the same thing
this is simple advice that's impossible
it's so hard but you know you got to do
it
and that is you need to tell your
father-in-law
hey um
we need to have a hard conversation
about work
and can we schedule that and he'll
probably say well let's just do it right
now
so you may want to
send him an email you may want to
um i hate to say this we may want to
even shoot him a text but my guess is he
loves you and he cares about you and
he's your boss
and he's going to want to have that
conversation right then
do you all have i'm sure you don't have
one-on-one meetings or anything like
that huh
i mean it's it's small i mean we sit and
talk you know just him and i a lot i
mean
so
and we have pretty open conversation
between us
it's just gotten a little tense
in the past few months
over this work situation
okay well how come
um
i'm ready to grow yeah i'm ready to do
more okay um but i'm still treated i
mean i've been practicing for
almost half a decade and um
how old are you even though
i'm 26. oh you just said that like a 26
year old i've been doing this for half a
decade or five years
[Music]
you said that like in the most
maximum way
i've been doing this a better part of a
decade which is like five years in one
day um yeah so you got five years
experience that's cool
how long has he been doing this
uh 30. okay so let's let's call what
what let's be honest about the whole
thing he's got way more experience than
you is that fair oh yeah been doing this
a long time is that fair
yes and this is his business that's fair
yes yes he can do whatever he wants and
he's got to treat you with dignity
and you can too
you can too i needed that john well you
can't i mean you're you're a grown-up
and this is a weird situation i don't
like
i don't like this
the only group i've ever seen do it
really well is
dave ramsey and his kids and his in-laws
they all everybody works in the bus not
all of them but many of them work in the
business and they are super clear they
call him dave at work they call him dad
at home they don't talk about work at
home they leave all the stuff here very
clear job descriptions very clear
performance metrics and that's that's
the way you got to do it you got to be
overly clear when you mix family
business you don't have that and that's
great and cool
man you want to go back to just being
daughter-in-law where he can dote on you
and do it on your kids and you all can
make jokes about your husband together
and
y'all do whatever at the holidays
um yeah yeah it's time for you to grow
so you just need to have a grown up been
doing this for half a decade
conversation which is going to be hard
uncomfortable
here's a couple of tips for that
say less than you think
okay
all right are you going to write this
down
i am i'm a note taker of course you are
you're an accountant say less than you
think
you don't need to go into a bunch of
explanations i've been asking for this
you don't need to do that
you need to say
i've accepted another position at
a another tax firm it's a significant
pay increase it's just a different level
of
of um
uh responsibility i'm so grateful that
you
got me off the ground i'm grateful for
the experience i've had and learning
here but i
don't say all that stuff because then if
he is any kind of boss he's going to say
i'll help you grow i'll he'll start
backfilling your reasons you don't need
to give him those
your reasons
are your reasons
all you owe him
is
the dignity of a face-to-face
conversation
not leaving him like if you've got all
these clients not just walking out of
there in 10 days like say i will commit
to i will leave with integrity
i will transfer these relationships etc
but here's my end date
and
um
i hope i
i look forward to just being your
daughter-in-law
and going from there
and then he
here's the thing
he has the responsibility to be the
adult in this situation be a be an adult
also not the be an
hear me very carefully write this down
and put stars around it and circle it
okay you are not responsible for his
response
okay your job isn't to make it okay for
him
your job isn't to make sure his his
his little heart is not sad
he gets to choose to be angry he gets to
choose to be sad
he gets to choose to have any kind of
response he may breathe a sigh of relief
and say oh thank god i just i didn't we
were kind of here now and i didn't know
it was next
probably probably not but maybe
you cannot own his response
it will be fair i think
for him to feel like y'all hid this from
him
and
yeah
it will be fair for him to understand
there wasn't a lot of i mean
if you'd come to him said hey i'm
looking for another job that would have
been weird too
yeah a lot it's a high pressure i mean
it's always high pressure where we are
october 15th is our biggest deadline
yeah you know with the personal tax
extension so i've been waiting until
after this date
to talk to him and i haven't gotten the
firm offer yet but i am not it's a 99
chance i will so i might not even have
this conversation if it's one percent
but yeah if it's not just bring donuts
and be like here we are and then back to
working with excellence but talk less
um
say hey i need 30 minutes of your time i
need 15 minutes of your time don't start
backpedaling don't start getting into i
just need a chance to grow it this is a
great opportunity financially this is a
great opportunity for you and your
family this is a um
it's got some neat new responsibilities
and you are so grateful for the
opportunity they gave you period into
that sentence
here is um
let silence be your friend not your
enemy in this conversation
yep i'm somebody who talks too much the
past year i've been learning the value
of silence i don't know it's been my uh
when i worked with lawyers i learned
this statement
the power and the pause
he who speaks first loses
yep
that that that's lawyer talk for how
they engage one another um
he who speaks first loses
there's power in the pause
and a lot of that talking talking
talking talking comes from
a lack of self-confidence
yep
from insecurity
you've been doing this for half a decade
half a decade
it's just the most millennial way to say
something um
i've been doing this for like a thousand
days oh you mean two and a half years
yes or three and a half years um
own your decision own your choice it is
gonna cause some challenges
hopefully he responds maturely what do
you think you think he's gonna respond
maturely or
no honestly i don't know
you do you've been working with him for
half a decade okay there's two different
ways he could respond one could be okay
great go take the opportunity to be
great because he thinks that i don't
have enough billable hours anyways
even though i have data to prove
otherwise but
he might be like okay cool awesome and
then after i leave he's gonna go crap um
and then
uh or or he'll say well what can i do to
match it we'll tell you to match it what
can i do to keep you because we need you
um so that's those are probably two
responses either one taking it
gracefully saying cool awesome go we'll
transition you out
um or
what can i do magic what can i do to
match it like like very frantic okay so
have you run that scenario in your mind
i'm just gonna tell them the decisions
made
if i'm you i would say i'm ready to go
just be your daughter-in-law
yeah i'm ready to go be your
daughter-in-law i like that okay i'm
ready just to be the mom of your
grandkid and the wife of your husband
and
a competitor in your community and we're
going to run you out of business old man
prepare to be crushed you can say that
too but i wouldn't but that'd be awesome
well i won't be a competitor so it's a
different kind of job
a different kind of job
so yeah i'm ready to speak i'm ready to
go back to being your daughter-in-law
and i'm so grateful for you and
appear in that sentence and then power
in the pause you don't have anything
else to say
all right that helps and you promised in
front of america and even some listeners
in germany and russia because evidently
we got those now too
um
that you're gonna call me back and let
me know how this conversation goes and
let me know call me about a week into
your new first your first new job okay
okay hey congratulations we we are
cheering you on
and if you end up with no thanksgiving
and christmas plans nashville is an
awesome place to visit congratulations
mandy talk less be direct be honest
you've worked for half a decade
you've got the rest of your life for
this guy to be your father-in-law we'll
be right back on the dr john delaney
show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best-seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndaloni.com and get
your copy of redefining anxiety today
all right we are back
all right hey john yes ma'am did you
know we've been doing this show for just
over one tenth of a decade
i just wanted to bring that to
everyone's attention
we
we've been doing this for one tenth of a
decade a little more than
i could have sworn it was about 8 000
hours but i guess that sounds right ish
right
we've been doing this for a
little more than a tenth of a decade it
feels like forever
kind of has been we should be getting
paid a lot more and what
never mind
we're all right cool let's go to kyle
and indiana that was hilarious way to go
kyle in indianapolis what's up kyle
hey john how you doing remarkable
what's up
well hey i got a little bit of a story
in question for you so i recently
switched jobs um i was in a good job i
liked it
obviously certain issues but overall
good place
ended up getting an offer for almost
double the salary so obviously that made
the decision pretty easy um and took
that job offer however now that i've
been in the role for about a little over
three months or so
i have been fighting with anxiety like
crazy from the moment that i got the job
offer and how to tell my boss all the
way to now like worrying if i'm
good enough to do the tasks at hand or
if i'm like meeting expectations that
aren't necessarily set
and it's been eating into
like my mornings feel terrible until i
actually get started i feel myself
procrastinating stuff during the day and
then i also end up
dragging it home with me after work and
talking to my wife about it for like
three hours running in circles of my my
worries and it's been
hurting that relationship as well even
though she's incredibly supportive of it
so just looking to get your suggestions
how to make this transition easier man
i'm
i'm really grateful that you called dude
so
what is
the anxiety alarms
like when you feel your body
what are they telling you
yeah so like the biggest thing that i
feel is like basically not in my stomach
um physically
and pretty much anytime that happens my
brain just starts running in circles
about like well what am i worried about
or what is my next struggle that i'm
going to be facing tomorrow or
my brain likes to go even farther out of
like oh man what am i going to do three
months from now and
basically worrying about meeting
expectations for things that i'm not
sure i'm capable of doing and not that
i'm probably not but how's how are you
are you doing a good job at this new
career this new job yeah
luckily the job is basically the same
job i had before just a different
company so okay so you know you're doing
the job
yeah i do it's the it's a
programming role so i've done
programming in the past and i'm doing it
on new technology so it's obviously a
little bit of a learning curve but in
general i do am capable of the job so
i'm gonna it's gonna sound like a left
field question
um
how much is this new salary
yeah it's a hundred and sixty okay
um
how did you grow up financially
uh middle class i would say nothing we
didn't starve for anything but we
weren't um
well off per se
okay that was my that man i should do
this for a living
so
you've heard of imposter syndrome
oh yes okay
so impostor syndrome is about identity
it's not about what you can or can't do
but it's about who you think you are
okay
um
clara i think it's is it clear claire
joseph she says imposter syndrome is the
fears of other judging of others judging
ourselves the same way we judge
ourselves
it's the fear that others are going to
judge you as bad as you're judging you
and when you grow up middle class not
well off
okay nobody missed a meal we didn't
worry about stuff but really there was
some worry
when you grow up like that you have a
picture of what people look like who
make that kind of money that you now
make
so this is not about can you do this job
because you know you can
this is about oh i'm one of them now
and thems don't have i thought
everything was going to be okay when i
became of them
i thought my marriage would be fine i
thought the car would be great i thought
the house would fix i thought all this
stuff would happen
and this feeling in this in your body i
don't belong in this room
because i'm not one of them has nothing
to do with the job capabilities
hear what i'm saying yeah i do i've made
this jump myself
i did not grow up with a lot my dad and
my mom they worked their butts off we
didn't have a lot
in fact there were some seasons when
things were real hard growing up
and i have had some major identity
issues because i knew folks who did have
a lot
i knew them they were my friends i loved
them and i had fantasies about how their
lives were all great and perfect and
wonderful and this and that's and they
had these vacations and these cars etc
etc and the more i've
worked with those folks behind closed
doors for the last five 10 15 20 years
i've realized
oh their marriages fall apart too
and they may not be starving for food
but they're starving for connection
they've got challenges x and y and z i
also learned that the more money you
make
the more people expect you to do
like people you earn that money right
yeah that is very true and i didn't know
that i thought that when you just got a
certain job everybody high-fived and
they're like all right you're here
here's this new salary you're the
associate vice president or you're the
vice president you made it
welcome grab a cigar here's your salary
i didn't realize that when you became a
vice president
oh man things got real hard like they
pay you for that
and they may not pay you to paint but
they pay you to make sure there's paint
in the warehouse and the whole business
doesn't fall over and so it may not be a
physical exhaustion on your shoulders
but that weight keeps you awake at night
because the whole building's resting on
your back you know what i mean
yeah and it's it's totally true because
like for example we have a project
coming up that
the one good thing about this company
that almost hurts me and this
conversation is they're a lot faster
moving than my other places we're given
a lot more flexibility to solve the
problems in our own way rather than
being told how to do them
and that leaves a lot of uh
thoughts in my brain even during the day
obviously but even after work of like
how will i go about doing it will that
be the way that is good or they want to
and
yeah that extra money makes me feel like
it's uh yeah listen it's a totally
different job even though you're doing
the same thing
it's easy to make 80 grand doing a thing
that somebody else tells you to do
because if that thing doesn't work
or you make it it's good but it doesn't
it doesn't succeed in the marketplace or
it doesn't make your customer happy you
point at the person that told you
it's a lot harder when you make a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars and
if you it's up to you to come up with
that client's gonna want and execute it
and see it done then that whole project
rests on you and so if the project fails
you fail right
yeah so it feels like the same job it's
not it's heavier and it's harder and
they're paying you for it they're paying
you really well for it
but it this is not about can you but by
the way you'll get better at that
you'll learn to carry that weight you'll
get stronger
think of it like you're three months in
to a double your salary job
i used to call it getting in shape
you've got to get in a different kind of
shape to run at that level and you will
so you feel underwater right now what i
want you to do is feel your body
don't run from it be curious about it
when it takes off on you don't go oh no
what am i i gotta
just smile and say oh my body's trying
to take care of me again this weight
we're lifting this is heavier than i've
ever lifted before think of it like
bench press or squats you can do it they
wouldn't be giving you 160 000 if they
didn't think that you could do it they
think you're going to make them 2 10 20
100 x that or they wouldn't pay it for
it to you so they think you're worth it
right
yeah i mean that's exactly it even some
more contacts a lot of people on my team
have 10 plus experience years of
experience and i have two and a half
done since college yeah it doesn't
matter that's another thing that plays
into it this is not about skill this is
about identity you don't think you
belong in that room
yeah i i can definitely see that
all right so
anxiety is three things it's it's it
means one thing it's an alarm system
looking for three things
am i safe
can i control my destiny do i have any
sort of sp say into what's coming next
and am i connected
and so let's just reverse engineer that
real quick you got friends
yeah i absolutely do
not in your business that you go hang
out and have a drink with y'all play
dominoes or whatever call of duty
whatever i don't know what's going on
y'all get together
yeah hold on hold on one second take a
break why you all laughing at me
dominoes
i love you
almost saying call of duty i was
thinking of call of catan i was trying
to i don't know i like dominoes kyle you
all too whatever i like you mentioned it
we just played titan yesterday with that
friend so you're right you're right on
track hey like them apple suckers
kelly and james drinking the hatred back
there so
by the way i'm coming out i just decided
at just this moment with delony dominoes
and they're gonna be incredible i'm
gonna make a million dollars i'm not
gonna share it i'll share it with you
all too sarah and connor not y'all too
all right back to you kyle
uh i will not sell it make any money off
delaney domino's by the way
um but
okay so
you've got some friends that you connect
with on the regs you got them together
yeah okay cool so
are you safe are you about to get fired
no far from it uh my company's strongly
against firing people so i really need
to screw up to get fired okay are you
gonna screw up
i sure don't plan on it all right does
your well i don't think any of us do
does your
wife support this move
yeah she's the biggest proponent the
biggest helper of it okay can you do the
job
i believe i can nope back that thing up
can you do the job yes okay
so you're safe
can you can
are you in control of what happens next
ah
that's a loaded question it is okay so
so hey so there you go
so
there you go
i think your brain doesn't register you
as safe right now because it knows those
people and you're not one of those
people and it is identifying those
people is not yours
you have left tribes you are out of a
community
your body is saying you're not safe
and what you've got to do now did you
lie on your resume
no i my skills line up very well great
the only time you're an imposter
is if you lie
if you say you can do something and you
can't so you're not an imposter
what you have to do is to begin to
see yourself as one of them you're
somebody that makes 160 000 now
and yeah you're still the same good guy
and you still are giving and charitable
and kind and you treat your wife right
and do you have kids i do not okay if
you ever have kids you're gonna be a
great dad
you are one of them now and by the way
there is no thems we're all just
figuring out what's next for us
right this idea that i know those people
that's just such nonsense but our heads
do it trying to find a gang
here's what i want you to do i want you
to and i've done this in my life and
it's been extraordinary
i've reached out to people at new new
places where i've worked new companies
and said
i want to watch how you level up here
you're in meetings that i've never seen
you have conversations on a scale at a
pace
and can we just have coffee once a month
and i'll learn
don't go to somebody be like hey may we
be my mentor don't do that but ask
somebody in another department who's
been there ten years five years take out
a couple of guys once a month that you
work with that have been there ten years
and just say hey tell me about this
business how are things and what you'll
do is you'll learn their jokes
and their conversations you'll learn to
speak their language and your brain will
begin to settle in because you'll
realize they're just like me
they want to be good dads or they're
terrible dads or they're goofy or they
laugh at stupid stuff or they think this
movie was dumb or funny
they've got car trouble too they're just
like me
they're worried about the future and the
economy and the bills and they're just
like me and your brain over time will
say okay this is my these are my people
this is my gang
does that make sense that's true
yeah absolutely does okay
and when it comes to are you in control
of what's next tell me why that's hard
for you
why is that a double-edged sword
uh so my job falls very highly on uh i
get a ticket says go implement x
and then i go do that for however many
day or two days okay the issue is in my
previous job i there was a whole backlog
of once i finish this i'll work on that
after that i'll do this so i knew what
my next two three weeks were going to
look like the new job uh i know what i'm
working on tomorrow most of the time but
there's a good chance i do not know what
i'm going to do after that
and i am a major planner uh as dave
would say like i'm the uh i'm the nerd
of the group yeah and so when i don't
know what's coming up tomorrow morning
case in point even today it i feel
extremely out of control in that regard
i love it all right so you've just
we've just pointed our finger at two
of the main drivers for your alarm
systems going off
so here's another thing i want you to be
highly intentional about okay
practicing ambiguity
they're paying you
for the ambiguity
they're paying you for your flexibility
you are a professional pinch hitter
you are no you're not a pinch hitter
because you're in the game you're a
relief pitcher
you're a closer you don't ever know when
you're coming into the game you know
what the score is going to be what
batter is going to be up but when you
get called in it's game on you don't get
to like a starting pitcher who knows
five days in advance what the you know
who they're playing who the batters are
what the rotation they don't none of
that
you just got to come in warm up you got
15 more pitches and you're on
this is just about learning to be okay
with ambiguity and what i'll tell you is
that something you can practice
how do you practice it keep a small
journal with you at all times
and when you start feeling like i don't
know what i'm doing today i don't know
what i'm doing today i want you to write
that stuff down get it out of your head
and get out of your body
all right okay write down
i don't know what i'm what project i'll
be working on today
my body is trying to
my body is looking for stability and
continuity and i don't have it in this
new job and they pay me an extra 80 000
a year
to have things a little bit shaky that's
what i accepted
but i know this when i get there
i will
crush that thing
because i have the skills and the
talents and if i don't i'm gonna say
and
hold on to your hats here kyle
i don't know but i'm gonna find out
that's okay to say that
right
yeah that totally makes sense so can i
tell you one last thing before we go
absolutely
you're totally normal man
three months in you are totally normal
you snow globed your life
you shook it all up you got a new job a
new place you're a new money you got a
new identity you think you do but you
don't everything's new you got a new job
y'all are running twice as fast as your
old job you're doing the same job but
it's actually kind of different
man
you don't know the rules your body's
alarms are going off and that's okay
i want you to make sure you're doing the
things that are going to keep you well
that you're sleeping that you're staying
connected to your buddies you're playing
dominoes or a call of catan or whatever
i don't know weird
games you people play
i want you to make sure you're
exercising make sure you're eating right
make sure you and your wife are
connecting and talking and that you
aren't keeping secrets from her and
she's not keeping secrets do those
things that keep your body well
and then
be really intentional about noticing
ambiguity be really intentionally about
noticing safety
be intentional about developing
relationships at work and i'm telling
you my guess is
in a short season your body will level
up you'll begin to squat this heavier
weight or bench presses heavier weight
and you'll be off to the races
and there's a tiny tiny tiny chance that
you won't
and if you find yourself six not six
months that's two a year two years three
years
and the anxiety is just killing you
then you have an honest conversation
with your wife with a counselor that
maybe this isn't the firm for you
maybe this isn't the job for you maybe
you need a little more structure in the
ambiguity it's not for you
what mo what we can't
wrap our heads around in this culture
is 160 000 jobs the stress and the
burden and the speed for some 160 000
jobs isn't for everybody
not everyone can handle that
there's some hundred thousand i can't
handle it
there's some half a million dollar jobs
that i can handle just fine it just
depends what the job is what the place
is what the roles
but that comes with an extra burden it
may not be for you and that's okay that
is super okay but have that conversation
later right same team
yeah that makes total sense
so take a deep deep breath as deep as
you can
hold it
do another one and hold it
nope
now let it out
i can tell on the phone drop your
shoulders all the way down pull them
down
it's like you're watching me pull them
all the way down man
you're not imposter you belong
you can do
this it's just heavier weight man
got it
i got it thanks so much john i'm so
grateful for you kyle thank you so much
for the call everybody out there
if you're going back to work you've been
off for a year you've been off for two
years you're taking i mean this was a
great resignation people are changing
jobs moving going all over the place
expect anxiety expect to not feel safe
expect your body saying hey this is
we're this is on our people they are
your people man everybody's the same
we're all trying to figure it out
whether you make a lot of money or a
little more i mean everybody's working
hard
doing the best they can but it does make
sense if you've never
seen quote unquote those people up close
before your body's gonna say hey not us
not us on us it is you'll get there
you'll get there be graceful with
yourself
stay connected to people
and buy some dominoes
unbelievable all right as we wrap up
today's show
man
it's one of my favorite songs of all
time i'm i am playing i love this song
i love love this song
i shouldn't play piano with with the old
mouth sorry
but the old face
kelly's just shaking her head in this
mixture of don't do that and shame and
sadness
songs by vanessa carlton if you don't
know this song
stop what you're doing because i'm about
to ruin everything go get on the
internets and find the song it's by
vanessa carlton it's called a thousand
miles
it goes like this
making my way downtown walking fast
faces past and i'm homebound
staring blankly ahead just making my way
making a way through the crowd
and i need you
i miss you and now i wonder
i don't know what this means but if i
could fall into the sky do you think
time would pass me by what
because you know i'd walk a thousand
miles if i could just see you tonight
i'm gonna repeat that that's how
profound that was if i could fall into
the sky do you think time would pass me
by
that means
because you know i'd walk a thousand
miles if i could just see you tonight
hey america
i'm not walking a thousand miles to see
you because you can just download this
download it right here the dr john
delaney shop